un plan de sauvegarde de l'emploi jugés
insatisfaisants
avec la crise du coronavirus la société
d'assistance aéronautique aérospatiale a
vu son chiffre d'affaires chuter 3 a
lancé un plan national de licenciements
sur les sites de méaulte carquefou et
toulouse conséquence un pse lourd à
encaisser rien qu à méaulte 139 des 150
postes devraient être supprimés
si les salariés concernés semblent
résignés à l'idée de perdre leur emploi
ils se battent pour obtenir un départ
honorable à des conditions supérieures
au minimum légal qui leur est proposé
pour l'instant est prêt prévoit le
minimum légal en fait en tout point que
ce soit en congé de reconversion que ce
soit en prime de licenciement qu il
prévoit le minimum légal
aujourd'hui un salarié chez nous il
partira avec 500 euros d'annuités ce qui
est la loi
donc pendant par année d'ancienneté en
tout cas et est donc donc tu sais c'est
intolérable on est dans dans on a
travaillé depuis 10 15 ans avait dans
l'entreprise et on estime qu'on a c'est
qu'on doit quitte à partir puisque si
crise sanitaire ya des difficultés il ya
on peut peut-être l'entendre mais on
doit partir pour pouvoir se classer
correctement et pour pouvoir avoir un
avenir et c'est simplement ce que les
salariés demandent aujourd'hui quatre
mois de formation équivalent à 3500
euros trop peu pour pouvoir se remettre
en selle selon la cfdt qui plus est dans
le contexte actuel loin d'être favorable
à l'industrie aéronautique
les travailleurs réclament des
indemnités équivalant à deux mois de
salaire par année d'ancienneté ils
s'estiment floués dans la direction
d'une entreprise pour laquelle ils ont
consacré plusieurs années de leur vie
sur les 1500 89 salariés et 800
intérimaires
le plan de sauvegarde de l'emploi
prévoit de supprimer 7 119 postes au
niveau national